la rouge salade purée gratin la blanche
au four bouillie ou en purée
la jaune en salade en purée ou en frites
recettes frites curé four ya de quoi
donner le tournis mais dans le monde on
en a retenu cinq mille au dessus de
saint émile variétés de pommes de terre
au québec qui ont pesé environ 125
variétés avec des particularités
différentes
la position est constante de la demande
aussi du consommateur est constant que
tout le monde se porte bien le camp qui
mangent moins une pomme de terre de
talent pour manger plus de chip où ils
vont manger plus de filtres pour le
québec
exquise à vivaldi merlin phoenix
rubiconde belda où elle porte de si
beaux noms mais on n'y voit pas sur les
sacs
on les choisit plutôt par couleur et
pour leurs fonctions c'est sûr que
d'arriver à tout mettre les noms des
variétés ça devient trop compliqué nous
ce qu'on voulait c'est servir le
consommateur
on a trois secondes à l'industrie pour
faire un choix donc mais un groupe icts
au g 20 les gens se retrouver on le voit
dans le vent
[Musique]
québec parmentier ses vingt-cinq
familles de producteurs dont les pommes
de terre mam'zelle qui ont réagi pour
freiner la baisse de consommation de
pommes de terre fraîches et ils ne sont
pas les seuls
event baisse assez constante du niveau
de consommation de pommes de terre
fraîches au québec un produit de
commodité que les gens trouvaient
probablement un peu limité au niveau
gustatif donc nous on sert 16
c'est quoi la différence entre des
manuels puis les pommes de terre que je
vais acheter à l'unité ou dans un sac
avec une couleur de mentionner qu est-ce
qui va faire qu'on va réussir une bonne
cure et une bonne frite ou une bonne
pomme de terre au four massalit qualité
physico-chimique de chacune des variétés
qui vont se retrouver dans sa gamme de
sauces et sa déclinaison pour christina
blais il existe trois grandes catégories
culinaire les couleurs nous a aidé à
catégoriser les pommes de terre il ya
les pommes de terre farineuse ca s'élève
à 7 se sont toujours brune langue avec
une peau rugueuse
ensuite il ya les pentes de tables
blanches et rouges qui sont rondes
ça c'est des pommes de terre qui sont
dit si heureuse parce qu'elles gardent
leur forme à la cuisson puis à la
variété intermédiaires qui est la jaune
alors j'ai choisi deux candidats opposés
d'une part les recettes totales des
pommes de terre rouge j'ai fait une
salade de pommes de terre
j'ai fait une purée de pommes de terre
puis on voit qu'une différence de
texture
avant même d'y toucher leur nient tout
change on voit vraiment ici le quai un
côté vraiment plus floconneux ouais
alors que les rouges c'est sait on voit
que ces puces est plus dense discret
mais c'est plus crémeux moi j'appelle ça
la neige à bonhomme vers ceux de l'af la
fille quand on fait du ski exactement
mon voile juste par les traces qu'on
fait d'eux dans leur rapport avec la
quantité et la qualité de l'amidon qui
existe dans ces deux variétés de pommes
de terre
étonnamment beaucoup différence au goût
c'est tellement plus goûteux la hausse
est plus goûteux mais c'est pas la même
texture que la rouge
ouais mais quand même bonne embauche la
texture
oui ok pas trop bonne vos patins si on
aime une salade de pommes de terre ou
les clubs gardent leurs formes dont on
va utiliser de la rouge parce qu'on voit
ici que youtube ne se sont pas des
agrégés on voit encore les arts est très
carré de 2 mai cube
mais si le cosy six rounds sans parier
l'on voit visuel exactement alors que
pour la recette en tout lien à la pomme
de terre en mélangeant tous les
ingrédients semblent elle va avoir
tendance à se défaire l'avantagent de
sens c'est que ça va boire la
vinaigrette les dix ou vingt livres de
patates se vendent moins mais plus de
vrac et de petits sacs qui se démarquent
souvent divin on va laisser ça dans le
fond du gard de roms qui ont venant à
perdre une partie donc pas de perte au
niveau du gaspillage tant au niveau de
la qualité que au niveau de la grosseur
et 5
si on achète en petites quantités puis
ça nous prend un peu de temps passe à
travers on est mieux de les mettre au
frigo
il ya des gens qui disent non faut
éviter le frigo ces personnes là ont
raison mais uniquement si on a
l'intention de faire des frites
parce que la pomme de terre au frigo va
changer son amidon en sucre et ça va
causer des problèmes au moment de la
cuisson des frites elles vont brunir
beaucoup trop rapidement
malgré son allure robuste la pomme de
terre est un aliment fragile c'est quand
même un aliment ou une plante qui était
sensible premièrement aux intempéries
qui est sensible aux vices qui est
sensible aux ravageurs on se cache au
pot on a mis des pesticides mais de
moins en moins on essayait de trouver
des solutions aux picots logique tout le
temps ça mais on a coupé à peu depuis
dernières années que 50 pour ça nous
faisait pendage de pesticides avec des
nouveaux produits à la pomme de terre
six arbitres c'est un légume puis égard
des marcheuses à s'adonner pas d'énergie
plus d'abonnements effectivement manger
des bonnes frites ça met de bonne humeur
la pomme de terre rouge est connu pour
contenir un peu plus de sucre que la
recette donc on voit la différence au
niveau de la coloration plus de sucre
plus de brunissement c'est la réaction
de maillard
la réaction de canalisations maintenant
au niveau texture là ça devient une
question de goût donc la recette en
théorie lorsque on la regarde elle est
floconneuse à l'intérieur puis elle est
un peu plus sèche en bouche alors que la
rouge devrait être un peu plus si un peu
plus mouillé à l'intérieur ça c'est les
frais des casse-croûte exactement il ya
un bon l'europe joie de goûter la moi je
dis rien j'attends ton opinion sur seb
davantage de l'afrique ni de casse
croûte
oui mais on voit que c'est plus crémeux
un embout mais moi je préfère c'est ça
c'est vraiment une question de goût on
sait par exemple que la friture ben
c'est la quantité d'eau qui remplacé par
l'huile pendant le processus de la
friture donc c'est sûr que si on utilise
une pomme de terre qu'une haute teneur
en eau ben on va obtenir une frite qui
va être plus molle qui va être un peu
moins santé parce qu'elle va contenir
plus d'huile heureusement pour les gens
qui veulent pas casser la tête la has et
ben là je pense que la rouge la blanche
l'agent m'a dit qu'est ce que je fais si
vous voulez pas vous tromper acheter
l'agent une pompe de teint qui est un
goût qui est super agréable pas trop à
man alors en cas de doute on choisit la
jambe c'est bon pour faire je vois pas
le peuple québécois pour moi jus de
pomme d'apple
je le vois pas ça fait partie de nos
racines c'est à nos principes
traditionnels puis c'est un bon quart d
entre eux qu'on est un pur fond et est
en forme et je pense garde ses soldats